[Music]
i'm
privileged i would say today to
have a discussion with senator mike lee
he's been the u.s senator from utah
since 2010
chair of the joint economic committee
since january of 2019 i'm going to get
you to tell us what that is and why it's
important
senator lee graduated from brigham young
university with a degree in political
science and gained his law degree
from byu's law school in 1997.
he started his career as a clerk for the
u.s district court for the district of
utah
and then clerked for justice samuel
alito on the third circuit court of
appeals
he served utah as governor jon
huntsman's general counsel
and reunited with justice alito who is
now on the u.s supreme court for an
additional one-year clerkship
he's written four books i don't know how
you find the time
quite frankly the freedom agenda arguing
for a balanced budget amendment
why john roberts was wrong about health
care which was an e-book critiquing the
supreme court's obamacare ruling
our lost constitution in 2015
and written out of history in 2017
he's been ranked by the new york times
using a nominate system developed by
political scientists to assess
political position on political spectrum
mostly left to right
uh as indexed by roll call voting
behavior as the most conservative member
of the senate
and i thought we could talk to senator
lee today about
well first of all about civics what
would be what what was called civics at
one point i suppose that you might have
been taught in high school if you were
fortunate
about the structure and function of the
us government and about
about the day-to-day life of a senator
um
and what that entails about the american
constitution in general and then about
about the issues that he sees as most
pressing
the con currently confronting
well the us in particular but also the
world so
thank you very much for agreeing to
speak with me today
thank you jordan it's really an honor to
be with you yeah well i
i we met just so everyone knows we met
in washington
that must be three years ago i think it
was in 2018.
i was very fortunate to come down to
washington and meet a number of
republican
senators and congressmen democratic
democrat senators and
congressmen as well trying to get people
to talk across the aisle and we'll talk
about that a little bit too about that
possibility so
you're an expert on the us constitution
uh from the legal perspective and
and you have lots of practical political
experience and so
maybe you could just start by talking to
us about how you see the
how you understand the structure of the
us federal government
well thanks for asking that question
jordan this is something i feel strongly
about
it's something that i think can help
lead us to a place where as a country we
can
heal where we can avoid some of the
pitfalls that
have proven problematic for us at times
the u.s government is
based on a document written in 1787
by a a group of individuals who i
believe were
wise men raised up by god to that very
purpose
whether you believe in god or not and
regardless of
what form of belief you might have when
you look at the us constitution you
can't help but
see that it has been an essential part
of a puzzle it's sort of fostered the
development of the greatest civilization
that human history has ever known it's
done this
uh and not because the document itself
has any magical powers or the words
themselves do but because the document
itself
recognizes that the sovereignty in our
system
are the people the people
have a right to be free
and that's something that's embodied in
our declaration of independence
written 11 years before the constitution
which we acknowledged
uh part of as a probably is a product of
the scottish enlightenment
and and how that spread on both sides of
the atlantic
that the power of government really
derives from the people
and that ultimately our sovereign is god
on earth sovereigns are citizens
government is an earthly institution
that
operates by necessity in order to
prevent
us from harming each other and being
harmed by others
in order to protect life liberty and
property
but ultimately we realize that
government is something of a necessary
evil
government is best understood i believe
as the official collective use of
force under the authority of a
rule of general applicability that we
call law
force properly understood is something
that
like anything else that we deal with in
the world that we find necessary
like oxygen like water like
fire for example absolutely an essential
part of life certainly
an essential part of any um thriving
civilization
but it's dangerous just like each of
those things and left unless kept
carefully in check it it will become
dangerous because it's run by fallible
mortal human beings that's essential to
our understanding of the constitution
is the fact that human beings have
infinite uh
uh and eternal value uh they are
flawed but they're redeemable and
we've got to make sure that power checks
power his government is forced
so within our system of government sets
up two
really important structural protections
to guarantee liberty
you see liberty and government power
exists somewhat in opposition to each
other
and yet at the same time they kind of
hold each other in check
government power authority force if you
will
cannot expand except at the expense of
individual liberty
to a degree we need this to make sure
that we don't
kill each other hurt each other or take
each other's things
but it's also got to be kept in check
at earlier times of human development in
some parts of the world to this very day
government has best been understood as
being embodied the government authority
is embodied in a single sovereign
a monarch a caesar a king a queen
in our system of government we recognize
that
immense danger exists in the
concentration
of power in the hands of the few and so
we split up the sovereign authority
to make sure that it really belonged
ultimately to the people we split up
government authority
uh along two axes first on the vertical
axis with something we call federalism
it was embodied in the text of the
original constitution and
later emphasized in the 10th amendment
adopted a few years later
but it says basically that most power in
the united states of america will be
exercised at the state and local level
by the people now there's a there's a
principle if i remember correctly and i
really like this principle i believe it
was developed in england
in great britain but i and maybe it's
part of the scottish enlightenment
that an issue should be dealt with by
the most
local authority capable of dealing with
it and so that's one way of deciding
of noting that authority has to be
distributed across uh
multiple levels but also of determining
who should be in charge
yes yes that's exactly right jordan and
in fact um
[Music]
we learned this as americans as part of
our experience
uh with colonial britain uh we we were
um
we were british subjects prior to our
revolution
and over a couple hundred years we
we learned something that i think the uh
the english crown discovered somewhat by
accident which is that
once you've established a community in
the
in the case of what became the united
states these 13 colonies
if you allow them to govern themselves
locally on local matters
it actually works pretty well and over
the couple hundred years leading up to
our revolution
we would go for these cycles where the
crown would exercise either more or less
influence it tended to exercise more in
the wake of wars that it had to pay for
it said more tax collectors those tax
collectors would impose more regulations
and then after a while they would
withdraw but we prospered
as they sort of let go so that's part of
why we were instinctively drawn to what
we
today call federalism or in other words
where we say
let's govern ourselves at the most local
level
possible just a few powers will exist at
the national level
the federal government uh is supposed to
be in charge of
national defense declaring war
regulating
interstate and foreign trade uh
bankruptcy laws
immigration laws postal roads there are
a few other powers but
you get the idea that's the basic gist
of it they're distinctively national in
character unavoidably national in
their impact all other things
aside from that default proposition of
where things are made federal
are to be kept local local people have
the advantage of being on the ground and
being able to see exactly what's going
on and
and higher orders um officials let's say
have the
advantage of being able to aggregate
large number of not large numbers of
people to do the same thing
at the same time but there's a tension
between those two things and so
and so you could think that there's a
level of responsibility for the
individual and for the family and then
for the local community and the state
and the
federal government and then
hypothetically international
organizations as well
but you want the least amount of power
possible moving up
precisely precisely it's a very good
absolutely i think
yeah and you made you made a case for
force two things that i think will
strike some
listeners or watchers uh make them
curious
you made a case for force and you also
made a case for the
the embeddedness of the of the
constitutional system inside a religious
structure and associated that with
sovereignty
and and um i mean sovereignty
historically as especially if you go
back into the deep past has been
associated let's say with
the divine right of kings or emperors
there's always been an association
between
political sovereignty and something like
divinity and
and that that connection although church
and state are separate it
isn't severed entirely in the united
states there's still that
that that's the case you're making and i
think it's a general case that
that connection still exists and
necessarily exists so let's look at
those two things you talked about
the government as as uh in in
relationship to
force and and why start there
that's what government is government is
force
the the only reason we have government
is force and bad things happen
i ironically uh violence can ensue when
people
start to think of it as more than force
if they look at government
as the arbiter of all that is right and
all that is wrong
of all that is fair or unfair
expectations
change and all of a sudden force can be
brought to bear
where it ought not tread under the
banner of government
force is there to make sure that we
don't hurt each other or take each
other's
things to make sure that we're protected
from those
on the outside of our country who seek
to harm us
and those who are within it who would
destroy us and our rights
um so i think these problems
become more pronounced when we lose
sight of what government
is we develop an almost reverence and
it's almost like it's become the new
idolatry we worship government
that's why i wanted to concentrate on
your on your discussion of force so
what i understand from that is that i
have a domain of rights
and you have a domain of rights and
we're going to bump into each other
there's going to be conflict at the
place we
touch where our rights might conflict
and what that'll mean is that there's
the possibility of conflict breaking
out there and that might mean that i'm
going to use force on you or you use
force on me now
we could cede the right to that force to
a different to a third party to another
authority
and that takes away the necessity for us
to use force so
for example um i remember
years ago i can't remember he was the
governor of massachusetts he ran for
for president
he was asked at one point uh about an
about an
escapee from a prison who uh michael
ducati
that's right that's right who who who
was then
um raped someone and dukakis was asked
about his personal response that what
how he would have responded if
that had been someone he cared for for
who was attacked for example and
he uh he
his response wasn't he didn't allow
himself
to to um what would you say to have the
kind of anger that you would have if
that sort of thing
happened and then say look of course i
should would be put in a murderous rage
as a consequence of that
occurrence but i've ceded that power to
the government
because it's too dangerous for
individuals to have to seek retribution
and retaliation on their own
if if that was always the case we'd have
nothing but constant
a constant state of warfare between
individuals and so we cede that power
and that has something to do with the
government's
monopoly on force at least under some
circumstances
and so yes that's that's a much well
it's a much different viewpoint than
thinking about the government as
something that's
that's the benevolent provider of goods
for example
right right exactly and and doc
braderson that is
that is not to say the government is
incapable of good things
and that government doesn't do good
things that don't directly
involve force it is however important to
remember that that's
ultimately what government is is force
the way government
does things the way it does anything
everywhere at least in our country is
that it collects taxes from the people
uh
we have a number of different kinds of
taxes in this country as they do
in many countries but ultimately that's
how government operates
and while we call that a voluntary
system and in many ways it is or is
supposed to be
ultimately we pay those uh citizens pay
those
because they know that if they don't pay
them
force will be brought to bear people
will come
and there will be penalties attached to
it if they don't pay them
that's that's why it's so important to
remember that government is forced it
uses force
to do things that we need it to do and
as you say it would be chaos
it would also be terribly inefficient it
would result in all kinds of problems
if every one of us had to be our own
sheriff our own
uh department of defense our own army
and our known navy
uh that would be problematic just the
same
having delegated those things to a
government we have to remember what
government
is why we have it and utilize government
for that which only
government can do and not a tribute to
it uh benevolence
and omniscience and an omnipotence that
most people
reserve for deity if they believe in god
i want to get some back to another point
you made a moment ago
about the role of religion i i'd
re-characterize
one of your observations about my
comments there
i i don't believe that the the
constitution
requires uh in order for it to work for
anyone to cling to any particular
religious belief or for that matter to
any
religious belief at all in fact by its
own terms
it carves those things out and makes
clear that government can't mess with
those
uh but government also may not establish
those things
it's important to have that boundary now
that but the
the they're uh i think what you're
referring to there is
my comment about the fact that it helps
to understand these things if as was the
case
in america at the time of america's
founding and as i believe is still the
case
with most americans when we understand
that
we are subject to an all-knowing
benevolent and all-powerful creator to
whom we will stand accountable at the
end of this life
and when we understand that our rights
and our existence
come from him and are a result of a
bestowal of
of his blessings rather than that of any
government
i think that helps inform the proper
role of government and the proper
relationship between the people and its
government there seems to be a
supposition in the declaration of
independence
that writes that there's a relationship
between rights and divinity
and and that is i think you can think
about that
conceptually rather than purely
religiously
although you can think about it both
ways is that there's a hypothesis that
there's something
transcendent about each individual that
that isn't subject
to earthly definition let's say that
always escapes definition that's what
makes it transcendent
there's a transcendent value in each
individual and the best
way that we can describe that is in
religious terms
in fact when we start describing it the
description becomes religious
and so we use language like the soul and
we think of
our rights our rights as something that
are intrinsic to us and of
the highest possible value and
that that is an assumption
that has to be made before the declarat
before the
the statements that are in the
declaration of independence can even get
off the ground
that's why the people who crafted that
document said
that they held those truths to be
self-evident
it's an a priory presupposition that
there's something transcendent about
each individual
and that's where sovereignty is placed
when i've done
my attempts at historical analysis you
know
in in monarchical systems there's a
relationship posited between the monarch
and divinity and the monarch
is sovereign because of that
relationship with divinity and it's a
complete
transformation of the view of humanity
that
occurred over thousands and thousands of
years and certainly manifested itself
in the american system that that
sovereignty is actually something that
is inherent in each individual not just
the aristocracy or the monarchy or not
just
not just any single group of individuals
aristocrats or
or any specific group but in each
individual
and so that's that's exactly right and
were we
not the offspring of god created in his
image
it would probably be harder to recognize
that and to accept that
as the a priori supposition
because the inherent worth and the
infinite value of each and every human
soul is part and parcel of this concept
of liberty
now i want to be very clear i know a lot
of people who
who don't share my religious beliefs who
share another
and a lot of other people who don't have
any religious belief at all and don't
believe in god they too all of them
are are capable and are rendered no less
capable
of living in freedom uh than i am
just the same one cannot mistake
the significant influence of a religious
belief system
like that that most americans share
about the existence of a god
and the existence of a redeemer the
other thing that i think is important
about that conceptually again
and the reason i insist upon the
conceptual level is because
of the dangers of associating this with
any particular religious
viewpoint or even with a religious
viewpoint at all for that matter because
as you said
the constitution works just as well for
atheists or it's just as applicable
um there is some real utility i think
in positing that ultimate knowledge lies
beyond you
you know and if you look at if you're a
totalitarian
let's say you're an atheistic
totalitarian which and those things
don't always go hand in hand but
generally they do
um there isn't anything
even hypothetically beyond your system
of knowledge
but if you're if you're a believer
if you're someone with faith then you're
forced into a position where
you always have to admit your
fundamental ignorance because
you don't have the answers at hand
that's that's reserved for something
that's beyond you
or something that's beyond and so i've
often thought that there's a real useful
humility
that's part and parcel of of belief in
something that's transcendent
because you leave what's omniscient
well outside of you and you understand
that that's something that you always
approach but never
can possibly attain and that all your
systems are
partially incomplete at best
and that seems to me to be a necessary
antidote to
like a a potentially dangerous
totalitarianism or narcissism so
and i so i think the system is set up
that way
i mean it puts attention in it because
there's there's is this
nesting of the political system inside a
a set of religious suppositions
but then there's also this insistence
and and
of the separation between church and
state so that's a strange tension and
it's
it's a tough one to to sort through
but um no no that's right and it can
seem
um it can seem contradictory it can seem
like it's in conflict
i think once you unpack what government
is
and and how it's used and you understand
human beings and their relationship to
each other
and to their government it becomes
easier
to see how this can work and how it must
work
in other words for me at least
um my belief in
my relationship with god is
uh the most important thing
um in this world to me it's it's right
there with my relationship with my wife
and my children
it's something without which i
cannot imagine my existence
and it is for that reason and not in
spite of it
that i don't want government touching it
in other words
there there is an increasing inclination
in
society today in including among many
americans that if something
is really important then it must be
something that the government
does promotes funds
uh or or is otherwise officially
in uh involved in um
and i think it this is a helpful example
to all of us of the reasons why it ought
to stay out
it is it is because it's important that
it must not touch it
it's not an appropriate place for the
use of force there's a good reason why
people have for many many centuries
sought sanctuary in places of worship
people instinctively recognize
that force the use of
physical uh physically coercive force
is not something we want to to take
place
inside of a church or or a synagogue or
another place of worship
and uh so too with many aspects of our
lives that are important
because they are important you don't
necessarily want government in charge of
it
so it brings up a really complicated
question which is
how do you determine so
how do you government can become
dangerous because of its monopoly on
force and its potentially expansive
reach
um but there's many complex problems
that need to be solved and
and hopeful hopefully people of goodwill
can work together to solve them
you're faced then with the necessity of
a constant discussion about what
government could and
couldn't do and it seems to me that that
discussion should be informed by
realization that government does
some things that are necessary but that
like any other
powerful entity it it's
it needs to face constraints part of the
political debate is constantly about
what
that domain of action should be and what
those constraints should be and i
suppose the conservatives are constantly
on the side of
pushing for constraint at least in some
domains on government expansion
there's exceptions to that and whereas
the people on the left
end of the spectrum are are more
convinced that
you know the the power for government to
do good
is so great that its power should be
expanded outward
that that's right and and it's important
discussion to have
and you've got you've got conservatives
and you've got
liberals we've got libertarians who
um you know i consider myself a
conservative with libertarian
libertarian leanings um
in any event regardless where you would
categorize yourself it's important to
recognize
what government is what it's not and
what its power is and and which level of
government op to be operating
uh for a particular issue and uh
which person or office within which
level of government
is appropriate so a minute ago we talked
about the the federalism the vertical
separation of powers
leaving a a fairly stable pyramid-like
structure
a few powers at the top most powers at
the base close to the people
most people know their state legislator
their city council members
they interact with them at the grocery
store they might recognize them at their
child's baseball game
fewer people know their federal
legislators as part of the reason
why we have fewer powers and trust at
the top there's also a horizontal
protection
in the constitution one that says once
you're inside the federal government
dealing with something that's a federal
issue you know war powers
regulate trade or international uh trade
or commerce and so forth
we're gonna have three distinct branches
we've further subdivided the king or the
caesar the king or the queen the monarch
there
into three distinct parts we've got one
branch of government the legislative
branch congress where i work
that makes the laws this was designed as
the most dangerous branch that's why
it's made the most accountable to the
people
at the most regular intervals because we
have the power to
prescribe the rules by which the rest of
government operates
that's the legislative branch the
executive branch headed by the president
in our system
uh has the power to execute implement
and enforce the laws passed by congress
then you've got the judicial branch
headed by the supreme court
that has the power to interpret the laws
and disputes about the laws where they
come into conflict
between two or more parties properly
before the jurisdiction of the courts
when each of those branches stays in its
lane
the legislative power remains the most
dangerous branch
but it is made less dangerous by the
fact that it's the most accountable to
the people at the most regular intervals
so insofar as we follow those guidelines
uh the vertical protection of federals
and the horizontal protection of
separation of powers
this document really has helped us and
it's helped us prosper
it's it's led more people out of poverty
than any government program ever could
or ever will
because it unlocks unlimited human
potential by restraining government
over the last 80 years or so we've seen
a system by which unfortunately under
the leadership of
white houses senates and houses of
representatives of every conceivable
partisan combination
we've seen a shift in power we've
distorted the vertical protection
of federalism by pushing power that
belongs to the states
up to the federal government then once
it's inside the federal government
you've seen congress responding to that
in a panic trying to shield
uh individual members from political
accountability that comes from all this
power they shifted out to the other
branches primarily the executive branch
by delegating it out okay so that's a
really interesting argument so
i i haven't heard that before so yours
my understanding of what you're stating
is so as
uh as increasing power has been what
you abdicated let's say to to the
federal
level or taken by the federal level
ill-advisedly
the weight on the individual
legislatures legislators the moral
weight has become too intense
and they're abdicating their legislative
responsibility and that means that it's
handed over to the executive is so
so i mean it's confusing for a canadian
well
our system is confusing for a canadian
but your system is
even more confusing for a canadian
the legislative branch in the u.s drafts
the laws but the prep
the president appears and this is over
many administrations to be using more
executive orders
and so this is a reflection of
what you just described is that the case
as far as it is
yes that is exactly what i'm saying that
is the culmination
of what we do when we ignore federalism
by pushing too much power to the federal
government okay so let me let me know
lawmakers choose
to this conclusion because it's a very
it's a subtle argument
so i want to walk through it again
we're you're basically hypothesizing
that at some point
the weight of responsibility becomes too
much for any single individual in a
position of power to bear
and so they'll look for avenues of
escape and they can't bear it maybe
because it's too complex they can't keep
up they can't bear it because people are
after them for making decisions
there's all sorts of reasons they might
be intimidated by the magnitude of their
decisions all of that so if you dump too
much on them
then they shy away from it and then it
defaults over to the executives
can you are there do you have like
examples at hand of that happening what
sort of powers are
have been taken away at the state level
or
abdicated where the states have
abdicated the responsibility and moved
towards the federal
and any idea why that's happening yeah
great question uh the best single
example
that i can think of lies with what we
call the commerce clause
clause 3 of article 1 section 8. article
1 section 8 is the part of the
constitution that outlines the powers of
congress
and with it basically the powers of the
federal government the commerce clause
gives congress the power to regulate
trade or commerce between the states
with four nations and with the indian
trust
over the first 150 years or so of our
republic this was understood
and exercised as a power to regulate
interstate commercial transactions
for example making sure that um
delaware maryland new jersey virginia
and pennsylvania
weren't engaging in trade wars against
each other
to make clear that the the federal
sovereign would be in charge of
interstate commercial transactions
interstate uh waterways uh roadways
uh things like that um and then
we had that would be because no single
state obviously could do that
because it involves more than one state
so the federal level is the logical
level
for that power to reside correctly
correct
and in that respect we were trying to
set up a you know a single
common market to make sure that we
weren't operating as 13
independent republics who would engage
in trade wars against each other
um all this started to change during the
great depression
during franklin d roosevelt's new deal
era
initially there was some resistance by
the supreme court but all of this
changed our reading our official
interpretation
of the commerce clause article 1 section
8 clause 3 changed
on one day in america it's very seldom
recognized in
a supreme court decision that very few
americans even know anything about
it's called nlrb versus jones and
laughlin steel company it was decided on
april 12
1937. in that case the supreme court
concluded that congress's power to
regulate
trade or commerce between the states
with foreign nations with indian tribes
not only meant interstate commercial
transactions
and the regulation of interstate
corridors of trade
and things like that but it also
extended to the power
to regulate any activity that is
commercially natural
and that uh when replicated across every
state
while local and interstate by nature has
an
in the aggregate a substantial economic
impact
such that something as uh as local
as trade and and labor laws or
agricultural production things like
agriculture labor
mining uh and things like this that are
economic but occur in one state had
always been the bread and butter
of uh something that if regulated by
government would be regulated by state
authority and not federal
in that case on that one day april 12
1937 the supreme court said no it's
it's anything that's economic and has a
substantial effect
ever since then uh congress uh
has enacted law after law federalizing
all these issues
labor manufacturing agriculture mining
uh
and so forth the supreme court has
left basically a perpetually green light
since that date
since april 12 1937 we've really had
only three instances
in which the supreme court has
identified any act of congress as
outside congress's
legislative authority to regulate
interstate and foreign trade
and basically all three of them two of
those three were sort of drafting errors
the supreme court explained to congress
how it could remedy and on the third one
congress went out ahead and papered over
the problem
uh by by validating the act of congress
in question
as legitimate under a a separate
uh provision of the constitution so as a
result of this
congress has now got all this power
congress then delegates that to the
executive branch
passing laws that sound uh less and less
like laws over time
and more and more like platitudes can
you give us any concrete examples of
that
yeah so okay now let's let's take a a
good example
let's say trade laws
pass something regulating the minimum
wage
uh prescribing a nationwide minimum wage
okay
that seems like a main issue that is
economic in nature
it has a substantial effect on
interstate commerce when aggregated
across every state
insofar as we just set the minimum wage
that is is not violating the horizontal
protection of separation of powers if we
set it
if however we were to delegate to the
secretary of labor or the president of
the united states or somewhat other
executive branch official
the power to prescribe rules making sure
that the minimum wage was set fairly
that would be
an unacceptable delegation of that
legislative power
over to the executive branch now we
haven't done that uh with the minimum
wage it's still an improper exercise of
federal power in my view
but at least we haven't exercised that
there in other areas
let's take for example clean air
clean air is something over which we
have
a basis for authority because if you've
got a factory or a mobile source of
pollution in one state
it can emit things that can move into
another state and cause problems
downwind
um but we've delegated a lot of what
power we do have in the federal
government
to executive branch agencies we've got
something for example called the clean
air act
now a lot of good has been done through
the clean air act we've uh
significantly abated things like acid
rain problems other air pollutants that
have caused a lot of problems for people
the clean air act this is a slight
oversimplification
but as i explained in in our lost
constitution it's a little bit like we
said
we shall have clean air we hereby
declare that we shall have clean air
and we hereby delegate to the epa the
executive branch agency in charge of
administering that law the power to
define
uh what air pollution means
what are acceptable limits on particular
air pollutants
than to prescribe penalties for those
who
exceed those limits and the power to
enforce those same penalties
all vested in one executive branch
agency
that might be good for politicians
because it allows them to say i like
clean air
but if if the epa then charged with that
does things that in some circumstances
make no sense like for example when they
set the
minimum ozone levels at a level below
where mother nature herself has set them
as happened in
some parts of the country people become
outraged they complain
to congress members of congress beat
their chests and say those barbarians at
epa
i'm going to write them a strongly
worded letter as if that were our job as
lawmakers to write a strongly worded
letter
when in reality all we've done is pass
the book to the epa
we've done the same thing with epa
as we have with occupational safety and
health requirements
with osha uh msha the the mind
uh uh safety and health administration
alphabet soup agency after alphabet
soup agency throughout the federal
government has law making powers that's
inappropriate
sorry sorry i should remind everybody
that there's a bit of a lag in this
conversation because of the technology
so we might interrupt each other and
appear rude but
the lag has something to do with that
and maybe me being rude also has
something to do with it but
there's all this talk about the deep
state
and and i'm just thinking that some of
that could well be generated
as a consequence of what you're
describing you know as
more and more decisions are are uh
delegated
or relegated more accurately to to
um entities that aren't accountable in
the same way
then it would seem logical that um an
extra governmental
government so to speak emerges i mean
the same thing happens in a country like
canada where the
the um the civil service becomes more
and more powerful across time
because responsibility is relegated to
it by
legislators that aren't or can't aren't
willing or can't
maintain their responsibility or is
passed on to the court
to make decisions to make law de facto
because the legislators won't take the
initiative to do so they can put it off
so
so what kind of what kind of reception
does this kind of argument
get among your peers and among your
among your political opponents
it's interesting dr peterson um
most of my colleagues in the senate and
our counterparts in the house
um would i suppose if they were part of
this conversation today
um say that they did they don't
necessarily
disagree with the fact that we've moved
power from states and localities to
washington and then within washington
we've given power away from the people's
elected lawmakers who have voluntarily
delegated that power
over to unelected unaccountable
bureaucrats and in many cases the
president of the united states
many of them perhaps most of them
would agree that to a degree that has
happened
what they would say next would depend in
part on their political persuasion
um some of them would say yeah that's
true
but it doesn't matter because this is a
good thing and we really benefit from
the
specialized expertise of those who
occupy these executive branch agencies
and i want to make very clear i i've
got nothing but respect for those
individuals they're
by and large well-educated hard-working
well-intentioned people with
a high degree of specialization my point
is not that we can't learn from them
my point is that they're not lawmakers
they don't stand accountable to the
people
uh in regular elections or elections
elections ever yeah well you said
for example you said that the epa
that that had had many positive effects
you're all you're you you seem also
still worried about it and so i might
object well if it's had those positive
effects
then what's the problem why worry about
it and
so i would like to to know that why
why is that a problem because
our government needs to be ours and that
means that the laws
a law consists of a set of words that
prescribe a rule a rule of general
applicability
imposing affirmative obligations on
members of the public
when a law thus understood is prescribed
in our system of government
by the federal government at the federal
level you have to follow a formula for
it to be legitimate
uh and that's true for not just the
philosophical constitutional reason but
also for the practical reason
that you don't want the law-making power
which is the most dangerous of the
powers of government
to be ever in the hands of people you
can't fire
they they work for you and you if you
can't fire the people who make these
laws as well educated well-intentioned
as they might be you got a problem so so
you see something like a drift over time
so that the legislative power drifts out
of the bodies that are supposed to be
exercising it into other specialized
areas and
and that escapes that escapes that has
the risk of escaping public
accountability
so i guess what you might argue then is
that the epa
and legislation like it produces some
short medium-term
positive outcomes but it has this
long-term potential payment
lurking in the background and we always
have to keep an eye on that
so but i mean what do you do about that
in this situation though because the
the power has been ceded to the federal
government and it looks like the
legislators can't keep up so
what's the solution or what are the
steps towards the solution
the easiest uh way that i can answer
that question because it
look it took us 80 plus years to get
here 82 83 years from the date i
identified to get here
the solution to that is going to take
some time it's not
simple but the concept is pretty easy
i think the important first step is to
enact reforms
including those that are embodied in a
proposal called the reigns act dealing
with regulatory policy another similar
one that i've introduced called the
global trade accountability act where
you identify policies that have been
handed over to the executive branch and
you say insofar as we're dealing
with the prescription the prescribing of
of laws the making of laws from within
the executive branch
we're going to treat those as
legislative proposals
that will then themselves be become
subject to the formula
ordained by the constitution
specifically article 1 section 7 of the
constitution which says that to make
a federal law you have to have
passage of uh the same set of words the
same bill
legislative proposal within the house of
representatives
and in the senate same bill's got to
pass then you have to present it to the
president for signature
or veto so your identifier you want to
identify
laws that have already been passed that
haven't had this
haven't undergone this process and bring
them back
into the house so to speak and that
document you're holding up that
particular book
what is that oh i'm sorry this is uh
the u.s constitution i carry this around
with me
you know it's it's pretty simple it's
only 453 words wrong
long but it's still very easy to
understand and
even though i've spent a lifetime
studying it and defending it
and i focus on it uh constantly in the
senate
i keep the document with me because
notwithstanding the fact that i'm very
familiar with it and happened for a long
time
i find that by having it with me i make
sure that i
can check what the wording says you'd be
surprised at how often it comes in here
i have a question for you about that too
like how do you how do you
check yourself against the standard
human propensity to have an opinion and
then to
justify it by recourse to
a hypothetical recourse to first
principles you know what i mean is
you're a constitutional expert and so
you've got this
whole body of argumentation at hand and
that would make whatever elements of you
that might
tend towards corruption quite dangerous
because you can justify that with the
knowledge
i mean and everyone tends towards to
corruption to some degree so
you know when you have that kind of
specialized knowledge then you have to
you have to ensure that the parts of you
that
might not be so um
aligned with the light let's say don't
use their knowledge in a negative way i
mean scientists
do that by trying to falsify their
hypothesis and then having other
scientists critique their work
and but as a constitutional expert i
mean i know you're accountable to the
people so that's a huge part of this but
do you have any other techniques that
you use to
to ensure that your conscience is clean
in relationship to
to your relationship with the
constitution
yeah yeah i do i do and that it connects
to something you mentioned a minute ago
refer to me as an expert in the
constitution i don't call myself an
expert on the constitution i don't
consider myself that i consider myself a
guy who has
uh a copy of the constitution with him
at all times
and who reads it regularly that's uh
that's what we need we we need fewer
experts and more people who just read it
and develop an opinion on what it says
and how best to implement
why did you fall in love with it in that
way i mean it's really quite something
actually that you carry it around i mean
and to me that seems like a good thing i
mean you're
if you don't mind me saying so um you
know it
you're you're carrying around something
that you want to be accountable to
and that's a that's a big decision how
did you come
how did you come to how did you come to
do that
i don't imagine that when you were 18
you were carrying around a copy of the
constitution
well um maybe you were always not always
i
i it started uh for me at
a young age the constitution was
something that was
um important to my parents and my mother
was a schoolteacher
uh uh who went on to have seven children
and um my father was a lawyer
and a professor of law later served as
as dean of
brigham university's law school and as
president of
brigham mayor university for a few years
when i was a child he was ronald
reagan's solicitor general
a solicitor general in our system as the
the government's chief advocate before
the supreme court
for the administration in question so he
devoted
his life and his career it died 25 years
ago
uh but um during
his uh 61 years on this planet he
devoted much of his career
to the constitution it's something that
we talked about around the dinner table
and something that he always taught me
was my responsibility to defend
i have also come to believe uh since his
passing he died while i was in law
school
that the constitution has never been
more important than it is right now
because it's the one thing that i think
can lower the emotional
temperature in this country it's it's
written
risen to an almost fever-pitched level
in part because we've misused government
we've mischaracterized what government's
even capable of and we've created
unreasonable expectations
the constitution's whole point is to
limit and restrain government power
because we understand that it's
dangerous
and one of the things that's great about
this is that it's politically agnostic
it's politically neutral
it doesn't require everyone to be a
liberal or a conservative
it simply says look here's how we're
going to make decisions
here's where decisions are going to be
made
for example i sometimes cite the example
that
people in vermont a majority of people
in vermont i'm told would much prefer to
have a single-payer government-run
government-funded healthcare system
perhaps sort of like what you've got in
canada people in utah
would not want that one of many reasons
why i'm not likely ever to live in
vermont
but let's let vermont be vermont let's
let utah be utah
vermont could actually go in that
direction much more easily more quickly
more cost efficiently
more completely if we allow them to do
it on their own than if we were trying
to
federalize everything which we have now
you'd also get the advantage of running
the experiment
i mean that's certainly one advantage of
a multi-state system with some autonomy
at the state level is you can run
multiple experiments and see which one
works
that's much better than than legislation
by fiat from the top
because you're likely to be wrong no
matter what your political persuasion
when you're trying to solve a complex
problem
well that's that's exactly right and in
fact uh our founding fathers
thought of the states as laboratories of
republican democracy
places where people could experiment
with what worked and what didn't work
states could learn from one another
follow each other
not by coercion not by coercive force
but by choice as people voted with their
feet
or with their ballot they could see what
was appealing to people
and what wasn't so yeah i support the
doctor
even from a leftist perspective because
you could say well look if you want
government to do good
then you want to put as much power as
possible as low as possible so that you
could run as many experiments as
possible
so that government could in fact do the
best possible job
whereas if you aggregate power at the
top you can make sweeping declarations
but the magnitude of your error is going
to be
is going to increase as a consequence
and that's a terrible thing because you
can be
really wrong yes
yes you could be really wrong but if you
split out the authority the authority
becomes less concentrated
and less lethal speaking of of lethality
this can manifest itself
even within the areas the the problems
i've identified
um manifest themselves sometimes even
within those areas where the federal
government
is clearly in charge
and the the the problem that we've had
is once we've seen this
um seepage that happens with the
legislative branch delegating out
its power in other areas where it's
exercising power that probably should be
federal in the first place
by habit like a dog to its vomiting it
continues the ritual
and it does so even in areas like the
war power federalist number 69
alexander hamilton explains that one of
the key features
of our system that differentiated it
from uh the
uh the british system that we had left
was the power to declare a war you see
that the english monarch had the power
to take the country to war it was
parliament's job to then figure out how
to pay for it and support it
hamilton explained we deliberately
didn't do that here we wanted the power
to
declare war only in congress over time
we've grant gradually ceded even that
power to the executive
speaking of vermont that's where my my
friend bernie has bernie sanders and i
but probably absolute opposite ends
of the political spectrum within the
senate there are a number of areas where
we agree this is one of them
uh we are uh really upset about the fact
that the war power
has been bastardized it's been
commandeered by the executive branch
with the
the acquiescence and in many cases the
blessing of the legislative branch
and he and i have been fighting for
years to get us out of an undeclared
unconstitutional
ridiculous civil war in yemen in which
the american people have no business
fortunately uh president biden's going
to get us out of it it's become
slippery to define war
you know it seemed to be more obvious
when it was one
set of uniformed men against another and
in two sovereign states and so i
mean part part of that slippage seems to
be a definitional matter but
i suspect as well given your arguments
or
at least along the same line that it's
somewhat of a relief for the legislators
not to have to bear that responsibility
yes and i think you're right i think
some of that has has changed a little
bit because times have changed
it's one thing to just declare war
against france spain
germany the united kingdom whatever
country
might have been named in centuries past
than it is
uh uh to make a broader declaration of
our region or against that philosophy
today
but then again then as now
one could propose that congress declare
war
on bad people now it would be a terrible
idea i wouldn't vote for that
but at least you'd be subjecting it to
the political process there would be
some political penalty
for any one crazy enough to vote for a
war
against all bad people why well because
that concentrates discretionary power
immense discretionary power ultimately
in one person the president of the
united states that's a bad thing
and and we ought to get away from that
but all these features that jordan have
crept
up to the point that we have glamorized
and we have imperialized the american
presidency
oh so one of the reasons why you saw
this chaos too i have a question about
that
this is particularly something
interesting from a canadian perspective
because i've often thought that there
are probably four branches of government
legislative judicial executive and
symbolic
and the advantage to the british
monarchy is that they
extracted out the symbolic and they
placed it on a monarch
and so you know there's a pronounced
tendency in people to
to to uh admire
leaders and to and to project something
like divinity onto them
and in from the outside in the u.s i
mean i see
the constant transformation of the
american president
and the american quote first family into
a monarchy like it was quite stunning
to me for example when i moved to the
united states in 1993
to see the sort of power that hillary
clinton wielded as the wife of the
president
that would never occur in canada under
our system that would be
essentially impossible but i i thought
that that was part of
the consequence of the executive having
to bear the burden of this symbolic
of of the of that that should probably
be be parsed out into the symbolic
you know because then the queen and the
king can be the
the object of admiration and the royal
family can play that role for people who
want that but then the executive is
free from that at least to some degree
so
i mean i'm not proposing that you
establish a monarchy but it does seem to
be something that's
like twist and you see that also in the
establishment of these
familial political dynasties um
that that's that tilt back towards a
monarchical form of government that
seems quite
unfortunate i would say dangerous that
is
that is an interesting observation i've
never thought of it quite like that
it is true that under our system of
government the president
is the head of state in addition to
being the commander-in-chief of the
armed forces
and the chief executive officer of the
you know of the executive branch
he's also the head of state it's a
gamble but
a risk or a a decision that we made
consciously as americans and i think
it's a very manageable
risk especially if you follow the rest
of the rule book
keeping in mind that that's no president
may serve more than eight years as
president
so that's the maximum time they're going
to have in some cases it's only going to
be four
and if if we properly managed our
government if
meaning if we kept the proper decisions
at the proper level and on the proper
branch
the president of the united states would
still be significant
but it would the presidency would be far
less emotionally
charged than it has become it's become
bubbling over it's become a seething
hotbed of incipient
uh uh tribalism and
it's it's uh really a scary so you see
that as well we've seen this in both
parts
you see that as a symptom of
of the movement towards excessive
executive power
and so you could think about that as a
principle is that if the
if the office of the presidency as it
becomes increasingly too hot to handle
that's an indication that too much power
has been
placed on the president placed at the
president's feet well that's an
interesting hypothesis i think
it's it's both an indication of that and
it's also the
uh in my view the foreseeable and
absolutely
inevitable result of doing that this is
just what
happens when you do that we have created
this
by allowing for the secretion of power
remember earlier in the conversation we
talked about the
the unique relationship between
force the use of government for force
and liberty
you can't really expand or contract
either one without affecting the other
one
but you know as we as we push this power
upward within the federal system
to the federal government and then over
to the chief executive to the president
power comes from somewhere it goes
somewhere ultimately that power comes
from the people and and accrues
within the executive branch of the
federal government
that's what makes it so darn contentious
because he's not only the head of state
and the commander-in-chief he's now
the in many ways the not just the law
enforcer
but also the law giver the lawmaker and
that's dangerous okay
that's okay so so let me
pull two things together here so you've
alluded during this conversation
i have too to the increasing political
tension in the united states
and so could you how would you
characterize that tension like what do
you think
what do you think is happening what
evidence do you have for that
and that would be a good start i mean
because i can't get my
i know it seems like things are hot i
don't know if they're hotter than they
were under nixon
i don't know if they're hotter than they
were during the vietnam war i i can't
tell but they're hot enough but
what's going on in your in your in your
view
[Music]
it's hard for me to compare um apples to
apples then versus now
um i i was uh a
a young child when president nixon left
office
and when he was working to get us out of
vietnam
i wasn't uh serving in the senate or
you know as a four-year-old i wasn't
terribly aware of all public affairs but
um but i have sensed just from my
reading of the history and from
my own anecdotal accounts of what i've
experienced in the last 10 years in the
united states senate
i've sensed the emotional tension
continuing to go up
there are some objective measures that i
think could help quantify this i'm not
an expert in those but
if you look for example over this 80
85 year period that i've been
referencing since the new deal era
prior to the new deal era in peacetime
the combined expenditures of all
of the states in america were always
greater during peace time
than the expenditures of the federal
government
since the new deal era the opposite has
always been true
it's always been the federal government
spending
more than all 50 states combined it was
never intended to be that way
is what it is growing has it grown
across that period
uh i haven't checked it in the last few
years but generally yes
and and in particular dr peterson the
share of our economy that consists of
government spending has itself expanded
rather dramatically
the most of the increase
has been federal but state expenditures
and federal expenditures combined
have as a share of of gdp in america
grown significantly since then and with
it the emotional temperature is gone
with it also you've seen the federal
government and the federal bureaucracy
in particular playing in more
heavy-handed and more ominous
looming uh role so for example 25 years
ago when i was
in law school the first time i i ever
sort of started thinking about this
executive
branch agency law making problem
we had a guest speaker come to the law
school
and he explained that
compliance with federal regulations
those prescribed by the alphabet soup
agencies
uh in the federal government we were
talking about earlier we're really a
kind of a backdoor invisible tax on
america's poor middle class because
americans pay
uh uh through the nose for those things
to the tune of
he said you know three about 300 billion
dollars a year and he said but they
don't see the price tag for that
what's what makes them devious and
hidden and manipulative
is that they pay for them but with
higher prices on goods higher prices on
services
diminished wages unemployment and
underemployment
that's how they pay for those things
because everything becomes more
expensive
and and that ends up being kind of a
backdoor invisible highly regressive
tax on america's poor middle class since
then it becomes independent
because of cost of of adhering to the
rig to the increasingly complex
regulatory environment
yes yes yes this byzantine labyrinth
of federal regulations uh uh
like the month you spend doing your
income tax yes yes
one of many examples it's now estimated
that you know well it was uh
estimated around 300 billion dollars by
our guest speaker 25 years ago they say
that that same cost is now somewhere in
the range of
two trillion dollars a year this is
immense
is it a massive expense uh
uh to the american people one that
disproportionately affects america's
poor middle class
just for comparison purposes the total
budget is
what's the magnitude of the total budget
now okay so
cobit is something of an exception but
we're trending
toward uh annual federal outlays in the
range of about
four trillion dollars we've exploded
that with cobit
uh spending several trillion dollars
more than that over the last year
we hope that's temporary we know that it
tends not to be completely temporary
when the minute you ratchet up spinning
it's something of a of a one-way ratchet
i also measure some of this
um in do you actually think that's a
reasonable estimate
the cost of it the excess cost of
regulatory
adherence is half the budget is
equivalent to half the time
yes yes i mean there are
lots of estimates out there some say
that two trillion dollars
it doesn't really measure the whole of
it
uh there are others who say that it's
somewhere in that range
others who might try to argue it's a
little bit lower but there are some who
say that
the true cost is even higher than that
but yeah i think that's an accurate
measure
another somewhat imprecise but
interesting metric that i use
my office in washington trying to
remember whether i showed you this
while you were visiting if not i'll show
you next time you're there i keep two
stacks of documents behind my desk
one document is a few inches tall
it's usually either a few hundred
sometimes a few thousand pages long and
it consists of
the laws passed by congress in the
previous year
the other stack uh is in some years
13 14 feet tall i keep it in three
separate
um cases bookcases in
in my office it's sometimes as much as a
hundred thousand pages long
and it's last year's federal register
the federal register
is the annual cumulative index of
federal regulations
as they're released initially for notice
and comment and then later as they
become effective
well so that's a very interesting metric
too so that's ratio of
of paper necessary to document
regulatory change
yes it is prescribing affirmative legal
obligations
of the relative power of the of the two
institutions
so to speak yes in a sense no it's not a
it's not a precise measure because some
of that is not an apple samples
comparison
but a lot of it really consists of
lawmaking
these are new affirmative legal
obligations imposed as a
generally applicable rule on the
american people enforceable by the
overpowering
uh that force that is the federal
government the difference between those
two
stacks is that this small stack
one that's only a few hundred to a few
thousand pages long made by elected
lawmakers
the one that's 13 14 feet tall 100 000
pages long in some years
made entirely by unelected unaccountable
bureaucrats
that's scary yeah well it should be it
should be
it should be something that sets again
people across the political spectrum
back on their heels because
if government wastes its time doing
things that aren't necessary it's not
going to be able to spend its time doing
things that are necessary
prioritization is a massive problem
right there's only so many things you
can attend to at the same time
so you know in any country
where
there is a societal tendency
to trust the people and be skeptical of
government
we call that liberty in a society where
people are encouraged to trust the
government
and be skeptical of the people we call
that tyranny
but it's interesting it's interesting
though you know because
you you do trust the government in a
really deep sense you carry the
constitution around
and so i the reason i'm pointing this
out is because i just read something
a while back about the degree to which
young people
distrust institutions and i've found my
trust in institutions decreasing as well
over the last years especially
media institutions and i'm not pleased
by that in the least
but you like you you do definitely
have faith in the constitution and so
what are you so when you say to be
skeptical of government
you mean specifically something like the
tendency of
government to expand and overreach its
proper domain
yeah is that right i don't put words in
your mouth yeah but you are obviously a
patriot and you know
you have great respect for your
fundamental institutions and so
it's necessary to separate those things
out because
otherwise especially young people they
don't know what they can trust
and they need to trust something you
know it's really important
yes yes and another way of i'd put it
i i'd take exception to one thing you
said where you suggested that i
i trust government as evidence by the
fact that i carry on the constitution
and i seek to follow it
i'd turn that a precisely on its head in
other words
the constitution reminds us that we
don't trust government as an institution
we trust people but not the government
the constitution is
our key to making sure that we unlock
unlimited human potential by recognizing
the inherent dignity
and infinite worth of every human being
and that we show that respect
by saying that when we use force on you
as we do whenever government
acts we will do so respectfully
and in a way that's measured restrained
exercised at the appropriate level
and is geared specifically toward
protecting life liberty and property
if it's not those things we won't do it
we we need to have
trust and confidence in human beings
because they're god's creations
and because we we're all created equal
when we put trust in government itself
we're putting trust in
force now human beings while
redeemable and basically inherently good
are themselves flawed and flawed
specifically
in in the sense that they are
covetous and powerful and we've learned
through
sad experience throughout human history
that
when someone acquires power especially
power in
his or her own estimation that person
will eventually begin to abuse that
power
insofar as that person is allowed to
abuse that power
and so we we we have to compel the
government to work for us and remind the
government
that it is not the sovereign okay we are
otherwise people
the kind of definition that i was that
would that i was hoping for
so let me because of course we have
finite time i
i would like to turn our attention to a
couple of other things
um we talked we talked a little bit
about this rising tension
and you you described some of your
theories about why it's occurring
um are there what else do you see as
as characteristic of this rising tension
like what worries you when you look at
the united states right now or maybe the
western world as a whole but let's stick
with the u.s
what what concerns you what keeps you up
at night and
and and then maybe what do you think
should be done about it
i tend to believe that the erosion of
civil society
is uh is concerning meaning the
voluntarily uh associating
the the voluntary associations that free
people form
when they're allowed to be free and that
they form in the absence of any
government telling them that they must
uh or that they may or that they may not
they just do it and by that i mean
churches mosques synagogues fraternal
orders
charitable foundations universities uh
neighborhood watch associations
all of those things that operate as uh
an
organized entity outside the force of
government
those are things that have really helped
us i've often said that the twin pillars
of huma thriving of the human condition
whether in american society or anyone
else
anywhere else they tend to be built on
robust institutions of civil society
and free markets if you have those two
things
human beings can thrive they won't
always choose to do so sometimes they
will make
choices that will put them on a path of
self-destruction but if you've got those
things in place
and people make the right choices human
beings will thrive
you'll lift people out of poverty i
worry that
as we've put more trust in government
we've done so we've allowed the muscle
of civil society
and the muscle memory of free markets to
atrophy
[Music]
and so it's not just what we've created
through a a a a bloated government
that is the problem it's also what we
lose what we give up in the process
people become less connected uh the more
brooding the government's presence is in
their lives and that worries me
as does you know some of the things that
go along with that include
you know religious associations and
religious beliefs
and i worry that in many cases we have
traded faith
um either in an all-knowing
loving all-powerful god who will judge
us at the end of this life or even if
if if not that faith
in a set of principles by which we guide
our lives has in many places been
replaced and supplanted by an
almost religious uh faith geared toward
government
this is in a sense the new idolatry the
idolatry of our time
when i whenever i study the old
testament i'm struck by
how much they focus almost obsessively
on idolatry and i thought well that's
weird we don't really see a whole lot of
that here
in a sense we do when we worship mortal
institutions
mortal institutions with immense
military power
aircraft carriers government offices uh
four trillion dollars in annual outlays
that's an almost religious amount of
faith
toward something that is not god and
that doesn't bring us closer together
that you've also said in your own
personal experience that you can feel
the temperatures rising in the senate
say
and one of the things i was struck i was
struck by a number of things when i went
to washington on the several occasions
that i did
i was struck by how absurdly busy
senators and congressmen were with their
multitude of duties
and i it was completely
mysterious to me how any business ever
got done given that
i was also struck by
the lack of personal communication
between
people within political parties
in the senate and in congress but more
particularly across
and so well you said that you've seen
you've felt this rising tension and so
what have how have you experienced that
and what what's the consequence of that
as far as you can tell
well you know it's it's not good you
know across the board
the more issues there are where the
parties are inextricably
um are unavoidably at odds with each
other
it gets more difficult and i'm not one
who believes that we have to manufacture
uh or contrived unity where it doesn't
exist there are some issues on which the
parties really are
in genuine disagreement this doesn't
reflect mere petulance on the part of
politicians sometimes it can do that but
more than anything else it reflects a
genuine disagreement
among those we represent uh who feel
passionately one way
or the other so but sadly
as we push more power up to the federal
government
seems like the the more areas there are
for these potential conflicts that are
almost irreconcilable between two
competing
political world views well it's the
cause that makes perfect sense if what
you're saying is correct because
those conflicts should be resolved at a
local level and maybe in a multitude of
ways if they're not resolved and
popped up they're going to affect more
people and the conflicts themselves are
going to aggregate
right so right right exactly and just as
saying goes if everyone's family then no
one is
if if everything is is
an emergency then nothing is an
emergency and so too here
if everything is federal then the
federal government's not even going to
be able to do the few things that
only it can do things like immigration
laws
trade policy and and uh uh war powers
and so forth
and so you know the way i've tried to
deal with this
in my own life and my own service in the
senate um
is to find scan the horizon continuously
to look for areas where the parties are
not
unavoidably at odds with each other and
to identify allies and
done this in a whole host of areas from
war powers to criminal justice reform
fourth amendment government surveillance
uh due process protections and things
like that some of my very favorite
people in the senate
uh many many of them happen to be
people who are at the opposite end of
the political continuum
from me i've found i don't know whether
everyone's experience
is is similar to mine but in the senate
at least
we have more of an ability to get to
know each other than members of the
house of representatives
there are 435 of them there are only 100
of us
you don't get to know all of my
colleagues equally well but i have the
chance to get to know
uh uh most of them and it really is a
great experience and i've also found
that
my personal life why is it a great
experience i mean politicians don't
generally have
a good name so to speak you know i was
very impressed
on a personal level with the people i
met when i went down to washington i
mean they all seem
democrat and republican like their their
stories
of motivation for involvement in
politics were so similar they wanted to
serve their country
i had no reason to believe that that
sentiment was false
um the they they without exception
seemed like admirable people to me
um you you're talking about your
admiration extending beyond the limits
of your political party i mean
why is that what what are these people
like
apart from the media depiction of them
let's say
they're great people they're fascinating
people
they're people who love their country
they're people who
in in many many respects want
the same outcome that i want which is
opportunities for a thriving of the
human condition
globally certainly and especially here
in the united states
those ultimate outcomes are shared
by i think all 100 of us we do have
different theories and different
approaches about how to get there
the minute i'm able to see on any
particular issue
uh how that particular senator no matter
how much i might disagree with her or
him on a particular issue if i can see
why it is that they believe that their
policy competing with mine or at odds
with mine
really gets to the same nirvana like
outcome by
the same positive outcome it's easier
for me
to try to figure out whether there's a
way to reconcile the two approaches
there isn't always in many cases there
is not but
in a whole lot of cases there are ways
to get there
and that's an especially rewarding part
of the process
there's something especially rewarding
about
unexpected success about something
working when you don't expect it to from
the outside
yeah well that makes you smile i mean so
so there's something about that that
that must keep you going
and so what are you thinking about
something in particular like
something a concrete example of that
kind of success
yeah so uh referred a few minutes ago to
invoking the war powers acted
adopted in 1973 bernie sanders and i got
together to try to get us out of
civil war in yemen the first time in the
history of the war powers act
we got something passed in congress
before last
and unfortunately it didn't make it
through the house of representatives
before that congress ended
we got it passed again in the next
congress then we got the house to pass
the same thing
it got to president trump's desk and
unfortunately he vetoed it
uh we tried to override the veto we
didn't succeed um
but have you got a chance now yes not
only have we got a chance
but president biden has the last few
days announced that he's going to get us
out of yemen and assuming
he uh follows through with what i expect
out of that uh the entire issue would
mercifully uh have come to with the
right conclusion
um when i first started in the senate
really satisfying
oh it was fantastic it's a it's a really
fulfilling moment it's a
minor victory in in in a sense that it's
smoke
compared to other disputes and
compared to the number of people who are
aware of it but it's a huge issue
it's it's a big issue criminal justice
reform
something i identified as a brand new
senator about 10 years ago that i wanted
to achieve
i saw too many people within our federal
criminal system in the united states
being sent away to prison
sometimes for decades at a time for a
relatively minor non-violent defense we
had a case in utah that i became aware
of nearly 20 years ago
it's an individual a young man who has
become a dear friend since then named
weldon angelos
weldon angelos was caught selling three
dimebag quantities of marijuana
over a 72-hour period to a person who
as it turned out was a confidential
informant of
a law enforcement agency because of the
fact that he was carrying a gun
at the time a gun that was neither
brandished nor discharged in connection
with the offense
mr angelos was sentenced to 55 years in
prison
for selling three small sandwich bag
quantities
of pot it's ridiculous the federal judge
who sentenced them said that
they're hijackers murderers rapists
terrorists who don't get this much time
but i have got no discretion on this
case
and only congress can fix this problem
those
words were still echoing through my mind
when i got to the senate i started
reaching out
initially to some fairly liberal
democrats and dick durbin and i teamed
up
cory cory booker came to the senate a
short time later he joined up with us
we ended up passing the most
sweeping criminal justice reform law in
an
entire generation in december of 2018
with the first step
act and we brought judges more
discretion
dick durbin and i are still working on
another bill to finish what we started
there
example after example of things like
this that we've gotten done that are
gratifying that are rewarding
it makes it all worthwhile makes it yeah
i can tell i mean you light right up
when you talk about those things and
it looks like 10 years falls away from
you instantly
it's really it's really something to see
so
i can see that enthusiasm untrammeled
enthusiasm and still
belief that the system works which is so
so lovely to see
in an age of cynicism what's your day
like
let walk walk walk us through what the
what a day in the life of a senator
the day of life of a senator i'd like to
know
when the senate's in session when we're
in washington
each day is filled with the combination
of of committee hearings
um of votes on the senate floor inside
the senate chamber
um sometimes giving a speech or two
here or there maybe on the senate floor
maybe to some group that's assembled at
the capitol
meetings with constituents who have to
happen to be in town
and in washington and then uh
the balance of that time might be
reserved for
conducting interviews uh with reporters
from the media
and in many cases meeting individually
or sometimes talking on the phone with
colleagues
debating and negotiating the terms of
legislation uh
that you're pushing and you're preparing
for either a committee hearing or a
markup which is a vote inside of a
committee
um or for a senate floor vote
those those things take up an enormous
amount of time and
you noticed earlier that you were struck
by how busy members are it's true
we stay very busy um uh
motion shouldn't always uh be confused
with actual progress on
this or that issue but we certainly stay
in motion but it does speak to the
burden of the
of the job yeah there's no that's right
that's right one of my favorite things
that i do uh
at least once a week sometimes more i'll
meet with colleagues democrats and
republicans alike
and over a meal dinner or on other
occasions
breakfast we'll meet together we'll pray
together
we'll share our personal experiences our
own walk
through life and we develop a great
appreciation for each other
the fact that
[Music]
there is there's real humanity behind
the the political figures
that are known to media pundits
but the person needs to be understood
in order in order for the legislative
body to function properly
well that is a nice ending
i was going to ask you um what you might
say to viewers and listeners who
find themselves becoming cynical about
the political process but
i think that the last 10 minutes of this
discussion actually answered that
question
and so i'm going to i think i'll leave
it at that and not ask for an explicit
answer because the implicit answer is
much better
now i was overwhelmed with admiration i
would say
of the institutions that i had the
privilege of visiting
when i was in washington i think it's
the the current level of political
tension
disturbs me because so much of what's
established already is so great and
it works and and it would be lovely if
that was more widely known and the cheap
cynicism that passes for wisdom these
days was
casually was discarded so
thank you very much for talking with me
today oh thank you so much
if you can convince a democrat to sit
down with me
i would like that um i'll get right on
it i i'm sure there will be many look
lovely yeah
i don't know they might think being seen
with me in public is anathema
um it might not be because i can listen
so um and i think these like i think the
the net is an absolutely underutilized
resource for
political figures who actually want to
communicate with the public because
it's long form there's no sound bites
you can say what you want to say
you can bring your thoughts directly to
your
to the people that you serve with no
no intermediation and i know it's not a
trusted venue yet for for
people in the political arena but
i think it's it's an opportunity that's
waiting to be exploited
waiting to be used not exploited you
can't really exploit
long-form media it's not susceptible to
manipulation in the same way that
that the old media forms were
so people who are interested in
straightforward communication can really
benefit from
the advantages of these podcasts and
and youtube videos and i'll tell you
i've learned the
general public is a hell of a lot
smarter than people think
and hungry for information in a way that
no one would have ever
expected i think we were blind to that
by the constraints of broadcast tv
you know which had to assume that no one
knew ever anything
and that everything had to be compressed
into something approximating
you know 30 seconds to half an hour
people people don't need to be spoon-fed
that way
so no it's brilliantly put jordan and
and i want to thank you for seeing
that in this particular medium you've
harnessed this in a way that's inspired
an entire generation of americans to
utilize this resource as a tool for
healing
and reconciliation and understand it so
thank you for doing that
well i hope that i can see you again in
washington at some point
that would be wonderful and again thanks
again on
maybe you know in a couple of months if
you're interested we could talk again
and we'll we'll find some other topics
to go at um
you can tell us a little bit more about
what's happening in the current
government and
about what you think might happen in
what should happen in the future if
we're lucky i'd i'd like to hear about
all of that
i absolutely yeah any time uh
you name the moment and i'll join you
i'd love nothing more great
thanks thanks again thanks so much take
[Music]
care
you